[Music]
haven't you ever had those times in your
life where you just feel
all consumed with tasting something
again that you haven't had in years and
years that's really what i'm doing here
is bringing back
those incredible desserts those
incredible experiences that have gone
extinct
i put myself through this process of
resurrecting desserts because i truly
feel that a good dessert can change the
course of your day
i'm valerie gordon owner of valerie
confections and i'm also a dessert
anthropologist
the way this
project of resurrecting historic
desserts began
was in 2009 the food editor from the los
angeles times magazine asked me to
create a blums coffee crunch cake for an
article that she was doing
and it was this amazing full circle
moment because i grew up with that cake
i know that cake and i missed that cake
terribly
blums was an incredible bakery and cafe
in california there were eight locations
the last one closed in the 80s when the
article came out we literally received
125 phone calls from people going oh my
god i want this cake
so the desserts that i resurrected to
date are of course the coffee crunch
cake from plums
i've brought back the
banana shortcake from chasen's
the brown derby grapefruit cake is
another cake that i've resurrected
and now is soon to be the coffiesta
sundae as well
[Music]
the
anthropology of the dessert resurrection
is really one of the most
interesting parts of all of this
i start the research process at the
central library
there is a room and this is a very
well-guarded room called the menu vault
there are menus that date back for 150
years
i find that looking at the actual menus
is so much more gratifying than just
pulling something up online because
you're really getting to the heart and
soul of the place you're almost
transported
into that place at that time by holding
something that these people held you
really are
[Music]
then i email a bunch of people or i call
a bunch of people who
were natives to los angeles or whatever
city the bakery was in
to find out hey do you remember this do
you remember that we always used to call
this the adult sunday because this is
the one my mom would eat can they
describe the texture of a whipped cream
can they tell me whether there was
vanilla in it or not i'm pretty sure
they did one basic yeah recipe for
whipped cream and then flavored
accordingly right it was little kid
whipped cream one cherry yes
this is amazing like you have been
indispensable
i'm not particularly interested in retro
it is about reliving those sense
memories
it's sort of like when you hear a song
that was your favorite song from 1982
you're really thrown back
into that moment it's become this very
emotional very fulfilling part of my job
to bring these cakes back for people
[Music]
siggy ron hillmarsson is an icelandic
baker
with an unconventional oven
he bakes bread by burying it underground
where it's heated for 24 hours by nearby
hot springs
it's very common to see hot springs here
in iceland there is constant lava
crawling under us
this lava is heating up water and this
water comes boiling up on the surface
we could put it in the oven
but this is much more fun
iceland is one of the most volcanic
regions in the world with 30 active
volcanoes at any one time
that helps create an abundance of hot
springs some with boiling hot water
and siggy uses them to his advantage
he specializes in baking hoove abroad a
traditional icelandic rye bread recipe
that dates back hundreds of years
i know for sure that in this village
i can track it down
as far as late 1800s something
my grandmother taught my mother how to
bake this bread
and my mother taught me in the hot
spring rye bread recipe we have rye
flour sugar baking powder salt and milk
we put this in a pot we put butter in
the pot then we wrap it with plastic
foil and we put it down in our hot
spring hole for 24 hours
it's very
obvious to see if the ground is hot or
not
i never use a thermometer if i need to
check the heat i just use this one
our biggest challenge is rain
if it rains a lot these holes that we
are using can cool down
and if they are not hot enough obviously
the bread doesn't bake completely
[Music]
everybody eats our bread our visitors
the locals hot spring rye bread has a
unique taste that you don't get from
ovens
the texture of this bread is quite
special it's quite heavy it's not the
typical light bread
when you show this to travelers that
come to iceland and you see their faces
they go wow
then you start to think that this is
quite amazing actually
[Music]
extra
[Music]
in the middle of the french pyrenees
there's a cake that's been spinning
and spinning and spinning for over two
centuries
joseph here has formed a society to keep
the recipe going
and he's in charge of a cake with quite
the cake is a reminder that losing isn't
always bad as napoleon soldiers
retreated from russia they picked up the
recipe from several eastern european
countries and brought it all the way to
the pyrenees where many people including
joseph and his brotherhood have kept the
baking going
la
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
d
cakes cookies and brownies no we're not
going to show you how to make them
because they can be made with ease
thanks to betty crocker who was born in
1921 in minnesota well kind of
[Music]
in 1921 the washburn crosby company now
known as general mills ran a contest for
people to complete a puzzle for the most
coveted prize a pincushion yes one of
your very own
surprisingly a lot of people wrote in to
claim their prize but with a little ps
how do i make my sponges
they wanted baking advice
so the customer service department began
to reply and to make their tips seem
more genuine they sign their letters
betty crocker
betty because it was a cheery all-around
american-sounding name and cracker after
a board member
not being a real person didn't stop
betty crocker from having a very
successful radio show the betty crocker
cooking school of the air
with a different accent in every state
[Music]
betty crocker cooking
[Music]
but the lies don't stop there let's talk
about that added ingredient the egg
you don't need to add a fresh egg to
powdered cake mix but science says it
makes us feel like we aren't cheating
and we're better providers
so thanks betty crocker for making us
all feel like we know how to bake
[Music]
these little custard tarts these eggy
sugary treats are everywhere in portugal
here here and here some say the prestige
de belang is the original paste dinata
or custard tart
in this little factory through this
kitchen there's a recipe that has been
kept top secret for almost 200 years
oh not this one guys i can't get in here
i'm sorry
[Music]
okay i'm miguel clerini and i'm part of
the management of prestige blind
this special recipe you will only find
here at this shop we sell an average of
about 20 000 tarts a day in the summer
maybe around 40 000 cakes a lot of cakes
the stage the balleng as they call them
here are simple tarts really egg yolk
milk some flour sugar but it's how they
make them in complete secrecy that makes
these tarts a national treasure
we have six people knowing the recipe
in the family my father
my cousin and myself miguel ferina the
three chefs which is vitor dominguez
eliseo jamiro and carlos martinez
the recipe is so secret all the bakers
sign non-disclosure agreements to keep
the timeless tarts a true mystery
staged blind
is one of the earliest recipes at least
here in lisbon we know that the recipe
was invented in the monastery of
geronimo in the early 19th century
this one
once they have the recipe the chefs now
sworn to secrecy are giving keys to this
door they work inside the factory uh in
a separate room that we call the ofcena
in portuguese it's like the secret shop
or secret room they have to work in a
separate room because the process can
only be seen by them so today we haven't
found anyone
that uh explained the recipe as it is if
it happened well we probably would have
to lock him up in the basement and
throw away the key
no just kidding
okay secret keeper what's the best way
to eat one of these custard tarts
usually i like it simple but that's just
me most people like with a little bit of
cinnamon on top
this is the hard part of the job
[Music]
yeah this is super hard
i don't know how you do it